what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with invincible and in the last
video we basically left off with this
scenario where robot had basically
killed this alternate reality version of
mark had destroyed angstrom levy and
then basically left mark there with
seemingly all the different viltermites
who had successfully conquered earth in
this alternate reality being left to
believe that if they saw mark here that
mark was the one who killed everybody
and so of course mark does the only
thing that really makes sense when all
the vulture mites release one of the
vulture mites come pouring in that mark
has basically made himself look like
this alternate reality counterpart it's
the smart move right it's the most
genius thing to do make yourself look
like this other guy and then in turn
pass yourself off as that dude and then
basically just be like you know the only
reason why this happened is because of
how crappy the security is around here
and all that kind of stuff right and
then ultimately ends up bailing out
right he just manages to escape now a
lot of this is or at least seems to be
because the viltermites don't
necessarily question their leader right
they don't really question the emperor
the emperor's orders are kind of an
absolute sort of this dogmatic approach
to how they view the people that are at
least the person that leads the empire
and so kind of begging on that mark's
able to make his escape and then
basically goes in order to meet with
what would normally be the location of
the team team right like just like adam
eve and all those different guys all
just kind of working together as their
own superhero group when he arrives
there while he is able to find robot in
this alternate reality things happen
entirely different that what had
actually happened here is that this
alternate reality version of mark had
killed adam eve that the idea here is
that much like we've seen in the main
invincible universe they grew close
right he was here on earth he was a
superhero all that kind of stuff but
when his father showed up and enlisted
him in the mission of conquering the
earth in the name of the viltrumide
empire that mark did it mark actually
allied himself with his father and ended
up destroying adam eve and seemingly the
rest of his superhero teammates at the
same time and so it's one of those crazy
things because he literally is
responsible for the deaths of most all
the superheroes on this world now the
funny thing is he basically spills the
beans to robot and is like i'm not from
this universe like i'm not i'm not part
of any of this stuff right like i'm from
an alternate reality all i want to do is
get back home but your version of mark
here in this reality he's dead so you
don't really have to worry about him
anymore right it's not going to be a
major problem and so robot of course
agrees to work with mark the second
thing is that because there's so much
information to deal with here and
because the technological advancements
are so far that robot can only do so
much and so what they actually end up
doing is enlisting the mauler twins or
at least one of the mahler twins in this
alternate universe because the other one
had been destroyed by this version of
mark now here's the funny thing about
this when the main invincible universe
mark shows up here he doesn't tell this
guy that he's from an alternate reality
right that he's from a different
universe where he wasn't a villain and
didn't kill his brother or anything like
that instead he just kind of lets him
believe that he's basically turned over
a new leaf right the things are
different now that he wants to he's seen
the error of his ways and that kind of a
thing it's enough to get one of the
mahler twins on his side and then in
turn they literally just kind of start
going through and working on all this
stuff now the biggest issue is that with
him being vacant from the vulture mind
empire for days and weeks and months at
a time what he ends up doing is
basically recording a message and saying
that this you know that robot and i and
we've all been working together on this
whole thing to basically take the
information of angstrom levy and expand
the empire into other dimensions but now
that they know it's going to work
they're holding me hostage right and so
until they're able to make their escape
to some alternate dimension uh i have to
stay here you know i'm trapped and then
like once everything's done then i'll
basically you know i'll end up using
their information and then we'll either
hunt them down or we'll expand our
empire or whatever and he's just like in
broadcast right so obviously it's a very
very loose explanation here but it seems
as though the villager might have
basically bought it and the reason why
is because while you do have robot that
takes the body of one of the invincibles
and then basically starts injecting his
mind into it so he can essentially kind
of operate as their leader effectively
by basically duplicating mark himself in
terms of physical appearance that all
the vulture might start showing up and
the reason why is because as far as
they're concerned their leader is
basically in danger and they would much
rather see the entire experiment
destroyed and their leaders survive then
let their leaders stay there and see the
entire experiment come to success and so
what they end up doing here and this is
one of the things that really starts to
freak out robot and the mauler twin is
that they've brought quote unquote the
monster that in this alternate reality
what had happened is that robot had
never found a way to basically slow down
and really even just stop the aging
process of monster girl and so as a
result she kept getting younger and
younger and now she's basically an
infant but remember the younger that
monster girl gets the more powerful her
monster form becomes and that's why when
they unleash her right they literally
just throw her out there and then she
just starts freaking out not knowing
what's going on and basically turns into
her monster form this form is gigantic
it's just colossal in size right i mean
this thing is just it's it's it's
enormous right hundreds of feet tall if
not close to a solid thousand and so
because of this like they're like we
have to go right we have to get out of
here now this basically leads to the
portal being activated and mark being
able to go back home and then you
basically have a robot who ends up
taking over or just kind of appearing in
the form of mark and saying no no no
this all has to be stopped right you've
ruined the experiment this is a new dawn
for the vulture mind empire and we never
really find out what happens with them
directly or at least not in this story
instead we basically pick up with mark
once he arrives back in the main
invincible universe gets back home and
then sees adam eve right now adam eve of
course has lost a whole bunch of weight
here she's still pregnant but as soon as
mark arrives she wants to have nothing
to do with him and the reason why is
because he's been gone for six months
now this is not uncommon and it's
happened before in fact even adam eve
says that it's not the fact that you've
been gone for six months that's the
reason why i'm so pissed off at you
right i mean that's just that goes with
the territory you took off during the
vulture my war you were gone for a
lengthy amount of time what makes her so
angry here is that mark had gone after
angstrom levy on the possibility that
angstrom levy might come back at some
form at some point in time and might
attack them it was different when it was
just mark and adam e when it was just
them it's a whole different beast now
when she's pregnant when mark has a
child because when that happened and of
course she basically took off the ring
like she's she's done when that happened
what she came to was this realization
that she couldn't be in a relationship
with mark and be raising a baby worrying
about whether or not mark was going to
like take off or something like that
that mark now has a greater level of
responsibility than he did before he has
a responsibility to their child and it's
not a responsibility that he seems to be
acknowledging here and so because that
adam eve is like i'm done right like
like we're done we're finished i don't
want to have anything to do with you
anymore enter a nissa now this is going
to be one of the most controversial
aspects of invincible right one of the
most controversial things and i know a
lot of you guys have been really really
curious about this a lot of you guys
have probably heard of this so anissa as
you guys know where nissa whatever you
want to call it she's one of the
viltromites and she's really seemingly
the only female wheelchair mic there
more so than that she hasn't really
lived up to her bargain of basically
procreating like she's supposed to and
most of that is due to the fact that she
just hasn't really found a suitable
partner right that all pretty much all
the men that she's seen around the world
are just like average joes going nowhere
in life at least in comparison to her
they're just not on her level and so as
a result of that the only person she
wants is mark now here's where things
get exceedingly controversial a fight
breaks out between the two and she makes
it clear in no uncertain terms we're
gonna bang and you're gonna be the means
by which i start procreating this world
or start procreating in this world right
you're gonna get me pregnant mark
immediately rejects her and it's like no
that's not going to happen but what she
ends up doing is forcing herself on mark
and it's not even one of those things
where mark's able to like successfully
fight her off and successfully able to
push her away no she's aroused by the
fight that they're getting into which is
basically getting her more and more hot
and heated and then once she's able to
successfully pin mark she forces herself
on mark and then in turn basically
sexually assaults him and so as a result
of that like mark is kind of left in
this almost broken state right i mean
he's just kind of left crying left in
pieces and she's just like man up right
it'll probably take a few times mark but
like i'll see you soon right like i want
to do this a few more times until i
actually get pregnant right so one not
only does she assault him in that
capacity she also made it clear she's
gonna come back several more times and
do it again whether he wants to or not
now one of the things that robert
kirkman does here and that's what's so
interesting about this that mark's
reaction to this is such that he doesn't
break down the way that you would
probably expect him to but it does have
a massive effect on him and it's one of
those things where he doesn't really
make it clear instead he immediately
takes off and goes running to cecil at
the pentagon now i would surmise part of
this is because focusing on something
other than what just happened basically
gives him the ability to pretend like it
didn't happen or to give it no real
thought whatsoever and to not
acknowledge what he had experienced but
talking with cecil what he says is like
there's a massive problem here right
like robot is basically going to conquer
the world and that's the crazy thing is
that when robot actually shows up right
when rex shows up here like mark warren
season he's like no no this is a bad guy
right like rex is not what you think he
is like we thought that he was going to
be here like he was a hero that he was
here to save us but whatever happened in
his time out there in the flaxseed
empire changed him right and his idea is
he wants to conquer the world he wants
to take the whole thing over and that's
what's so crazy is because rex doesn't
deny it right when cecil is like okay
like these kind of things you guys are
lobbing at each other this uh this
warrants a longer discussion and robots
like god i really wish it hadn't come to
this and then just slashes the throat of
cecil like literally just rips it open
and then like where cecil just laying
there bleeding on the ground like rex
just like smashes his head just stomps
on his head and smashes it and then a
kind of fight breaks out between him and
mark but remember rex knows how to
overcome mark that where mark basically
destroys this robot remember it's just a
shell right it's just a thing that's
there that rex does not actually exist
inside that robot that seemingly well i
wouldn't say the motivations of rex all
the way back when he took on a human
form and then basically started using
robots to do his bidding well i wouldn't
say that the intention of doing that was
to conquer the world i would say that
intention was to basically ensure that
he could always be there to fight
alongside his teammates because it
wouldn't actually be his physical form
he wouldn't die that if his robot form
was destroyed he would just set another
one and then another one and another one
and another one but instead that
decision actually came to benefit robot
insofar that with his intention to take
over the world it's almost impossible to
destroy him now because when he
basically tells mark i know your
weakness meet me at your house
essentially indicating he's going after
adam eve that mark races off and that's
when like the beans get spilled even to
adam eve that robot's like yes mark like
i'm basically taking over everything but
i'm gonna make the world better humanity
doesn't want to be better so i will make
humanity better right i will drag them
into progress kicking and screaming if i
have to but it will happen and that's
kind of the crazy thing is because when
he admits to killing cecil in front of
adam eve then it's not even one of those
things where like mark's delusional
losing his mind going after his friend
or anything like that it's like yeah i
killed cecil he would have stood in my
way so uh he had to go you know and
that's that's just the way it is
pretty bleak when you think about it
because rex knows how to overcome mark
when the fight breaks out between the
two rex does the exact same thing that
he did before he emits a sonic pulse and
because of the fact that the the sonic
pulse is the weakness of the vulture
mites that while mark is able to
overcome or at least able to punch that
robot the stance or really the
information given to mark here is the
more you punch me the harder you hit the
more intense the pulse is going to
become mark doesn't believe him he
punches him and then the pulse becomes
crippling and so when the question is
asked by by adam eve like why are you
doing this his response is shut up and
he rips her leg off of her body right
like literally just rips the leg off of
adam eve and at this point she's just
laying there basically bleeding to death
and so she uses her powers for a brief
moment even though she's not supposed to
because remember using her powers could
potentially kill the baby and then
basically gives them a kind of out right
a kind of escape they immediately bail
out as fast as they possibly can they
just take off they fly into space and
with mark having made his escape that
rex in his human form is watching all
this unfold and it's like okay i really
wish it hadn't come to this because with
mark escaping and adam eve escaping the
superhero community trusts them and so
if they go back to earth and they start
telling the superheroes what it is that
i'm doing then the superheroes are going
to unify against me so he's like very
well let the slaughter begin and so at
that point when you have mark and adam
eve who basically end up flying out to
the uh to the vulture might base on on
the moon right adam eve has to kind of
use her powers to create a force field
and they arrived there in front of nolan
and mark's like you have to help me this
is when the massacre starts because at
that point you basically have robot
who's kinda like okay here are all the
people that could essentially stand in
my way and without giving any real
explanation whatsoever he travels to
every single one of these people and
executes them all no questions asked he
just kills every single one of them he
doesn't ask questions he doesn't he
doesn't like try to get them to
understand where he's coming from it's
just a full-on outright massacre now at
that point he actually ends up calling
in monster girl and doesn't necessarily
tell her what it is that he's doing he's
just kind of like you know i have this
genius idea that when we were part of
the flocks and empire that yes i kind of
got carried away with myself yes i i did
some things that i'm not proud of but we
made mistakes but we can fix those we
can do better this time and there are
things that we can do that would
basically make this world better that
was different than what we did on the
flagship empire right basically having
this discussion about how he just
imagines himself conquering the world
fancies himself basically eliminating
anybody out there who's the competition
and while he's having this conversation
with monster girl she has no idea he's
massacring everybody all these
superheroes across the world he's just
killing them all and it's just she's
totally oblivious i mean it even gets to
the point where like he annihilates the
pentagon and so during this whole thing
that's when it dawns on monster girl oh
my god like he's he's doing this right
now like this whole plan he has for like
how to basically conquer the world that
they'd have to remove anybody that could
get in their way and all that kind of
stuff he's running over that right now
like he's literally doing that as we
speak and once she realizes what's
happening she begins to freak out now
notice she doesn't attack and that's
because she loves him despite everything
that's happened she loves him so she's
not going to just readily attack him
right off the bat instead she tries to
understand what's going on and she even
goes as far as to say right like monax
her son from flaxsen tried to tell her
that uh that rex was a monster but she
didn't want to believe it right she
didn't want to believe that it was
actually true but then she gets angry
and then like like just wrath begins to
set in once rex makes his case and
saying like yes right like i knew how
deeply you had betrayed me and yes i
ordered the deaths of all those
different flaxseeds across the world
right across the entire flax and race
anybody out there who was basically tied
to the royal family the woman who had
your child i had all of them killed and
yes i tried to have your son killed too
and so where he's like am i a monster
yes but that only really means you and i
have a lot more in common than we
thought before and so it's one of those
things where when she says like why
would you do this i loved you he
realizes the past tense of that
statement that loved okay so you're not
gonna work with me here and so in turn
he brings in his robots and basically
drags monster girl away right takes her
away and then it's one of those crazy
things where he says you know there's no
point in struggling here but i want you
to remember monster girl above all else
you betrayed me first and then in turn
has them carry her away and then eject
her into space then he tries to have her
killed right he literally has her just
shot out into space where there's no
oxygen and no ability for her to breathe
and while there is more to the story you
know what i think this is a great place
for a cliffhanger i think this is a
great place for a cliffhanger rob core i
love you guys so much i'm sorry i'm
sorry i have to do this i have to
cliffhang you
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace